what we're going to do in this video is
discuss the difference between normative
statements and positive statements and
you'll see these words used usually in
an economic context sometimes a
philosophical one a normative statement
is one that really is a matter of
opinion maybe a matter of ethics
something that someone thinks is how the
world should be
while a positive statement is something
that it doesn't necessarily have to be
true but it's something that can be
tested
so what we're going to do in this video
is look at a bunch of statements around
economics and think about whether they
would be classified as normative
statements things that are opinions that
are a matter of ethics or morals or
whether they are positive statements
things that can be tested
so let's look at our first statement
this says paying people who aren't
working even though they could work is
wrong and unfair
so regardless of whether or not you
agree with this statement is it a
normative statement or positive
statement
well the fact that someone's saying it's
wrong and it's unfair this is pretty
clearly a matter of opinion so this
would be a normative statement you can't
test whether this is wrong or unfair you
would just have to believe that it is
wrong and unfair
now let's look at another statement
programs like welfare reduce the
incentive for people to work
is this a normative statement or a
positive statement
well it might feel a little normative it
might feel like this is an opinion but
it actually can be tested you could
institute some welfare program on some
small scale and compare it to a
comparable place where there isn't a
welfare program and see what it does for
incentives to work you survey people you
see how many people work in one
situation or another it might be a false
statement it might be a true statement
but either way it actually can be tested
so this would be a positive statement so
i'll put it
in this category
right over here this is a positive
positive statement
all right let's look at another one
this says
raising taxes
on the wealthy to pay for government
programs grows the economy is that a
normative statement or a positive
statement
well once again
this can be tested it might be true it
might be false maybe your test is even
inconclusive but it can be tested you
could try to run a simulation you could
look at case studies of countries that
did do this and see what happens to
their economy versus ones that didn't do
it and so this is even though it looks
like something that someone who favors
raising taxes on the wealthy maybe out
of fairness arguments something that
they would say
this statement itself is not normative
the statement can be tested so this
is
a positive statement
a good giveaway for normative statement
if it said something like it is fair to
raise taxes on the wealthy to pay for
government programs that would have been
a normative statement or we should do
this that would have been a normative
statement but here this is something
that's testable now the next statement
raising taxes on the wealthy slows
economic growth
is that normative statement or a
positive statement
well once again this might feel like
someone who is against raising taxes who
think it's unfair to raise taxes on the
wealthy something that they would say
but the statement itself can actually be
tested so this is also a positive
statement even though in some ways it's
the opposite statement as the one that
we just did
because once again
we could look at countries that did this
in countries that didn't do this we
could run a computer simulation to try
to understand whether the statement is
true now let's do one last statement
this says
the government
should raise taxes on the wealthy to pay
for helping the poor is this normative
or positive
well in this situation the word should
is a pretty big giveaway should or it's
fair unfair this is someone's opinion
it's not something that's testable you
can't test whether this statement is
right or wrong it's based on do you
believe ethically morally
that this is true and so this is a
normative statement
so i'll put it
in the
normative column
so big picture these words normative and
positive these are fancy words but all
they mean is normative is a matter of
morals or opinion and not can't really
be tested while a positive statement
whether they're right or wrong or
whether you agree or disagree with them
these are things that in theory could be
tested